foreign
[Music]
um
is
we
thank you very much mr president dear
vladimir thank you for your words and
thank you for welcoming me a second time
now here in kiev
i'm deeply touched and humbled by the
strength and the resilience of the
ukrainian people now two months after my
first visit
we see that the brutal fighting
continues in the east and in the south
but i must say it is impressive to see
how
strong the ukrainians are defending
courageously their country in this very
difficult conditions and the vladimir
we're mourning with you we share the
tears with you about the loss of lives
but i also see here in kiev
that life is bringing back
to keep
i see that people are clearing the
rubbles
you're building again the bridges
you are
starting to really returning people from
abroad they are coming back to the city
and this is a good sign
so today indeed we are here i am here to
to have a working session with you there
were many topics where we took stock
where we stand
first
i want to report on our joint work on
the reconstruction
together we are working on a
reconstruction platform it is amazing to
see there is an enormous will outside
ukraine to support the reconstruction
be it the member states be it other
friends and partners of ukraine but also
the international financial institutions
ngos citizens civilians and
of course business is very interested in
supporting ukraine for the
reconstruction what we want to do
together with that platform
is create
a common
direction of travel
have a very clear roadmap on how to do
how to deliver and how to orchestrate
this reconstruction full transparency
full accountability
to help ukraine rise from the ashes
this should be a process that is fully
owned by ukraine of course
what we can offer as a commission is
we have a long track record of
experience
how to manage those situation and mainly
how to manage the investment with
reforms
we share the same objectives we want to
channel the investments and deliver
reforms
so that we improve the lives of
ukrainians we rebuild ukraine we make
ukraine attractive for investors a
conducive environment for the business
sector and of course support ukraine and
pursuing its european path this is so
important to have the combination of
reform and investment
of course ukraine was already on a good
track
before the horrible and atrocious
invasion of russia
ukraine is a solid well-grounded
parliamentary presidential democracy
it has robust and well anchored
institutions
a functioning administration at all
levels i think it pays off now
that you did the reform on
decentralization we see it on a daily
basis in the work with the commission
that at all levels the administration is
functioning despite the war be it the
local level the regional level or the
federal level so there is a resilient
administration that is fully capable to
function for the country
under incredible circumstances
we see a country that is highly
digitized
my i told you already that my high
respect for the level of digitalization
you have it helps during this war
um it is a country where we have already
the association agreement the deep and
comprehensive free trade agreement
in other words we cover already large
part of the european aqui by that
and we know that as you've said more
needs to be done
to get me right
ukraine is at war
so your
focus
and our support
is in overcoming this atrocious horrible
war
but we want to look further
and with the reconstruction we also want
to look forward what needs to be done
next for example
you have done a lot in strengthening the
rule of law but there still needs to
be reforms
implemented to fight corruption for
example or to modernize this
well-functioning administration to help
attract investors
again the institutions are in place the
reform program you've undergone in the
last years pays off now now we need
results
and we have been discussing all these
different topics
in
our working session
as you know the commission is currently
preparing the recommendations of
so-called opinion for the eu member
states
we have been working day and night on
this assessment and i promise to you in
april dear vladimir that
we will be tirelessly working on it
so the discussions today will enable us
to finalize our assessment
by the end of next week
the path is known
it is a merit-based path forward
it is
a path where i must say i highly
appreciate the enormous efforts and the
determination of ukraine in this process
the people of ukraine have proven
incredible strength and motivation and
stamina
so i'm deeply convinced that
we will together you will overcome this
horrible atrocious war
we will and you will rebuild this
beautiful country and modernize ukraine
and i just want to say we stand by your
side slava ukrainian
you